l'état
la représentation nationale ont voulu
stabiliser le budget à louer aux
médicaments en France depuis 2007 et à
demander aux industriels et aux
régulateur l'os de dire de toute façon
vous avez un budget constant quand vous
avez des innovations qui rentrent vous
devez les les payer en réalité par une
diminution des produits qui sont sur le
marché depuis longtemps de telle manière
à ce que les produits qui rentrent soit
financés par les pros par la baisse de
prix des produits anciens on arrive à
une situation où pour citer deux et deux
extrêmes le médicament le moins cher de
France c'est le Lévothyrox 25 un
médicament extrêmement important vous
avez eu entendu parler du lévothyrox
dans la longtemps il y a eu beaucoup de
il y a eu peut-être même une commission
d'enquête sur le Lévothyrox il y a
quelques années le niveau de 25 il a un
tarif de 38 centimes d'euros la boîte 38
centimes pour fabriquer le médicament le
mettre dans le blister le mettre dans le
dans le packaging mettre le la notice ça
c'est 38 centimes d'euro voilà le
médicament le plus cher de France c'est
le transit il c'est un médicament qui
traite une maladie osseuse rare pour
52000 euros la boîte ce sont des flacons
c'est un traitement c'est un traitement
aussi Qui est qui est nécessaire
moi à titre là pour le coup de de
pharmacien et de citoyens
je trouve étrange cette écart de prix
entre 52000 euros et 38 centimes d'euro
le sur des traitements qui sont qui sont
majeurs les deux qui traitent des
pathologies majeures les deux un ancien
nouveau certes il faut payer la
recherche certes il faut payer le il
faut payer le l'innovation mais en tout
cas il est maintenant impossible et donc
la représentation nationale il y a des
étudiants un groupe d'experts qui est en
train de plancher sur le sujet mais on
ne peut plus on ne peut plus
continuer une politique de financement
de l'innovation par les baisses de prix
des produits d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs anciens vous ne pouvez plus
faire baisser le prix du lévothyrox de
38 centimes à 35 centimes et de toute
façon ça va rien financer du tout
on est arrivé au bout du système et donc
il va falloir avoir des des il va
falloir réfléchir et innover pour
pouvoir
dans notre pays pouvoir accéder aux
innovations mais avec des tarifs
peut-être plus raisonnables